brought to you by the PlayStation
original series powers watch the series
premiere for free on March 10th at
playstation com I can't let him get away
with it again I got to bring my a-game
on this one damn it close enough I know
you did it what's wrong with your face
I'm asking the questions here are you
pretending to be a cop let's start at
the beginning if CSI taught us anything
it's that the evidence never lies except
in those episodes when it does anyway
scouring your crime scene for vital
clues is obviously the key to any
investigation sadly in real life clues
don't glow have a pop up or make a peep
when you gravely cast your beleaguered
detectives gaze over them also regular
police are limited to not being
billionaires with technology that does
this to your surroundings and then
hopefully shoves all the clues through
some magical algorithm that does your
job for you that's what makes in the
world's greatest detective my arcs Izzy
but maybe it's because he's basically
doing the whole thing by himself sure
he's got Oracle and Alfred on the blower
and sometimes Robin pops in but trawling
through crime scenes and beating up
thugs must be lonely work so games have
taught me that to be the world's best
detective you need to have a partner in
crime well partner in enforcing the law
a Watson to your Sherlock a Luke to your
Layton ass and your max a vaguely
familiar television actor to your call
Phelps haven't they all been in CSI
alright so once you've tracked down
every last piece of evidence in order to
progress through the level now's the
time to really examine it closely turn
it over in your hand and tell everyone
in the vicinity what you're holding
anyway at least in games we don't have
to worry about waiting for weeks for
pesky things like DNA test results to
come back the only issue is that you
still have to try and select the right
test for the job here's where the powers
of deduction come in handy and luckily I
know how to read people of course it
helps that everyone becomes a twitchy
nervous wreck when presented with the
mere hint of an accusation it's pretty
easy to
point out a liar they jitter stutter
their words and look to the side a whole
lot nothing says guilt like side I once
you followed all those steps you've
definitely solved the case
congratulations sure you might have to
make some deductions and tie some loose
threads together but basically you've
caught the guy or at least you've caught
a guy now there's nothing left to do
other than take your gun and go out in a
blaze of glory what about the evidence
justice tell that to the courts so
what's this all in aid of again you took
my American mug don't try and deny it
yeah I've got it right here quiet you
I'm such a good detective that I know
you did it and now I'm gonna tell you
how you did it step by nefarious step
you're on the mug back so where'd you
stash it huh well I know could be on a
slow boat to China by now I wish I could
help you detective I really do